good morning John as I think this video
dftba records is on the front page of
youtube owning the front page of YouTube
on the front page of YouTube and on that
front page of YouTube we have won an
explanation of what dftba records is
starring me and Evan was tough guy and
to a son buy a little stuff Gann Tom
Milsom camped 3 video from our new
artists rhett and Link who you've
probably heard of because they are so
awesome their video is called live on
the internet and it features Shiba Inu
puppies and Snoop Dogg so that's a win
and for a new song from Alex day also
known as nerimon it's a really awesome
song Alex's olive isn't just good it's
the kind of music that I like to listen
to and it's so exciting for me the dftba
is releasing his album if you watch his
video which by the way was edited by
charlie is so cool like and edited
extremely well you might find a lot of
presence in that video for only people
who watch that video so you should
probably watch that video let's be
honest what's good for dftba artists
just good for me i don't have a flash
drug in my hand it's so beautifully i
got that one at an Auto Show like almost
all of my flash drives maybe I should
have a flash drive contest that sounds
like a horrible idea
I would never follow up on that mixing
that right now other amazing things that
have been happening lately last night I
got a message from a nerdfighter about
touring to Olympia Washington and while
maybe I will toward Olympia Washington
what really happened is that I got this
song by rancid in my head called Olympia
Washington and like took the chords and
I started playing it and I changed some
stuff around and then I was like
Katherine can you sing this song and she
knows the song so she started singing it
and we recorded it and Katherine totally
kicked ass
I thought her cover was done and then it
was really awesome and then I was like
ok so I'll just edit the video now and
then she was like but Hank we haven't
done the harmonies yet and I was like
harmonies and then she blew my mind so
you might also want to go to that I
think I'm gonna link to everything at
the end of this video I'm gonna have a
huge page with lots of links to
everything for annotations that's gonna
be good ok keep your eye out tonight
additionally truth or fail is doing
extremely well
our last host Dan Brown who did the
truth or fail for the Lost Symbol did an
absolutely wonderful job but the real
news there is that Dan Brown just got
picked
I am not kidding you to be a real
contestant on the real life who wants to
be a millionaire in real life I love Dan
Brown Dan Brown at the man and he is
going to be on Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire
I hope he wins lots of money and the
final thing before I link to all those
videos all at once
I was just editing this video and I was
watching and I saw some really
magnificent hand motioning there
let's review in slow motion all right
okay yes you're doing that yeah okay
where does that Oh
I don't give out of nowhere oh man
I'm dextrous and the final thing before
I link to all those videos all at once
is that I have realized in my quest to
create a tour of the western United
States that I don't know where you
nerdfighters are and when we did the
Tour de nerdfighting we use this thing
called eventful so you sign up for
eventful tell me where you are and not
you want to see me and then when there's
lots of people in specific places then I
go to those places and that way I can
like differentiate between going to
Tucson and going to Phoenix that's just
one example everyone even if you're not
on the west coast should go to event
full and tell us where you are so that
John I know where to go when we do
nerdfighter gathering that would be
great there is a link in the sidebar now
here's the time where I show you all the
videos that I said that I was kind of
like too and here they are all linked
licking up licking a Big D lolly keys
make any move click on the one you want
to go see and then if you want to see
another one come back